[Musique]
bonsoir lundi 16 mars édition spéciale
sur tv 78 consacrée à la pandémie de
coronavirus et au premier tour des
élections municipales dans les yvelines
voici les titres sept décès 174
personnes contaminées par le coronavirus
dans les yvelines derniers chiffres
local communiqué sur cette pandémie qui
s'installe en france est désormais en
stade 3 toutes les écoles et les lieux
recevant du public non indispensables
sont fermés ambiance à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines forcément en
raison du contexte lié aux kovy 19 le
premier tour des élections municipales a
été marquée hier par une participation
historiquement faibles plus de 16 points
en moins par rapport au scrutin de 2014
un report du second tour est désormais
dans toutes les têtes
et puis tv 60,18 vous faisait vivrière
en direct la soirée de ce premier round
des municipales dans le département et
dans cette édition retour sur les
résultats les enseignements et réactions
avec les candidats engagés
la pandémie de coronavirus toujours plus
présente en ile de france au dernier
point publié hier dimanche à 15h par
santé publique france 1209 cas étaient
recensés dans la région mais vous le
savez ces chiffres évoluent très vite
dans les yvelines le dernier bilan qui
nous a été communiqué par la préfecture
des yvelines
elle nous fait état de sept décès 174
cas confirmés dans le département et
dans ce contexte les collectivités de
tous niveaux région département
intercommunalité ville s'organise pour
faire face à la situation avec notamment
des fermetures de services des services
qui passe aussi au télétravail
écoutez à ce propos pierre bédier
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines
il ne suit plus action
l'extraordinaire exceptionnelle jamais
eu donc pas dire sera pas braquer toutes
nos équipes sont mobilisées pour que
l'enfant de nos collaborateurs restent
chez eux soit confiné soient tentés dry
sauf les collaborateurs indispensables
hausse avec des offres
je pense en particulier à l'aide sociale
à l'enfance on va pouvoir continuer à
accueillir dès l'enfance france je pense
également un ami et puis de vanves rire
des collèges pour permettre l'accueil
des enfants des personnels
réquisitionnés dans le cadre de la lutte
contre la tendinite donc on n'est pas
prêt à organiser
j'ai pas fait mal mais on fait dans
l'ordre dans les yvelines la vie des
habitants et forcément impacter chacun
essaie de s'organiser comme il le peut
dans la perspective de nouvelles
déclarations présidentielles rappelons
qu emmanuel macron s'exprime ce soir à
20h les magasins les magasins
alimentaires sont pris d'assaut tandis
que les autres commerces sont tous
fermés drôle d'ambiance ce matin dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines comme ont pu le constater
patrick jacques de dixmude mathilde et
demi et nicolas kirillovitch ce sont des
affiches désormais placardées sur les
devantures de nombreuses enseignes comme
partout en france les restaurants cafés
autres salles de sport ont leurs rideaux
baissés à saint quentin en yvelines
parmi les derniers commerces encore
autorisés à être ouverts les
boulangeries la queue pour acheter du
pain si fait entre angoisse et sérénité
à d'habitude on achète une baguette le
boulanger s'étonner enfin pas
complètement mais il est habitué à ce
qu'on prenne une baguette à chaque fois
on fait un peu plus de coursan même si
on n'essaye pas de réaliser les magasins
parce qu'il en faut pour tout le monde
ferait en 83 ans
j'ai quand même vu la guerre j'ai quand
même vu pas mal de choses donc je prends
les choses comme elles viennent
chez comme tout le monde j'ai fait
quelques quelques réserves de conserve
quand même une chance est pas une
maladie ouvert aussi les hypermarchés à
proximité de la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines cette grande enseigne a été
prise d'assaut
conséquence les entrées étaient filtrées
en début d'après-midi une ruée vers les
courses qui avaient débuté dès ce
week-end après le déclenchement du stade
3 par le gouvernement dans ce
supermarché de guyancourt il était
difficile de trouver certaines denrées
quelques heures seulement après
l'ouverture du magasin
le rayon pattes on l'a remplie hier
matin et ont commencé à vouloir tout
mettre et des cons remplissait ça
partait donc on essaye de le mettre de
l'europe et une fois par jour parce que
sinon des corrompus c'est vide dont qu'
on essaie de faire profiter le maximum
de clients de pâtes et de doré de
denrées alimentaires de base en fait
pour servir le plus grand nombre nourrir
les personnes mais aussi nourrir les
animaux les animaleries sont elles aussi
autorisé à l'ouverture à coignard les
propriétaires de chiens chats ou encore
lapins étaient nombreux ce matin à faire
quelques réserves dans la perspective de
nouvelles annonces gouvernementales
mon lapin mange qu'une sorte de foi qui
refusent l'alimentation en grande
surface donc du coup je viens faire des
provisions pour lui puisque on sait pas
où on va on sait pas pour combien de
temps la petite commençait à manquer un
petit peu de nourriture donc comme nous
risquons effectivement un confinement on
s'est dit que ça pourrait être
intéressant de
resto qu'un tout petit peu farouches
stocker c'est beaucoup dire mis à part
les commerces alimentaires la totalité
des magasins étaient fermés dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines aujourd'hui donnant des
impressions de presque fin du monde
ce parking d'ordinaire bondés est à
peine rempli au tiers aujourd'hui et des
restrictions qui ne sont pas sans impact
sur la vie économique du territoire
dans ce bar d'habitude très fréquentée
du coeur de l'agglomération l'ensemble
des vingt salariés sont désormais au
chômage technique priorité le personnel
priorité les fournisseurs avec
peut-être peut-être une petite
restriction
sur sur les charges locatives le loyer
les choses comme ça on a besoin de
trésorerie
bon il se trouve que le bistrot du
théâtre existe depuis 25 ans on a un peu
de réserve mais ça fond comme neige au
soleil social culturel économique c'est
toute la vie des saint quentinois qui
est impactée par la propagation du
coffee 19 une vie au ralenti qui
pourrait durer de nombreuses semaines et
avec la décision du gouvernement de
fermer tous les lieux accueillant du
public et non indispensables à la vie du
pays la vie normale vous l'avez vu dans
ce sujet 1 se retrouvent à l'arrêt à
l'image de la culture plus de cinéma
plus de visites aux musées de monuments
plus de sorties au théâtre à titre
d'exemple le château de versailles
fleuron du tourisme yvelinois est fermée
tout comme les châteaux de trianon les
jardins le parc aussi la galerie des
carrosses ainsi que le domaine de marly
autre exemple parmi tant d'autres le
théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines où devaient se tenir les
rencontres in cité l agglomération a
décidé de sa fermeture dès vendredi
comme pour l'ensemble des équipements
publics du territoire
autre secteur touché c'est le sport
toutes les fédérations ont pris des
dispositions pour interdire la pratique
en compétition mais aussi en
entraînement une décision prise dès
jeudi soir après la dernière allocution
présidentielle
à l'instar du football qui compte le
plus grand nombre de licenciés dans les
yvelines
plus de quarante mille personnes en tout
qui ne pourront plus disputé de match
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
samedi le club de voisins-le-bretonneux
se réunissaient pour faire le point sur
la situation et organiser la suite les
propos sont recueillis par mathilde et
demi la fédération française de football
via noël le graet a très bien réagi je
pensais rapidement puisque dans l'heure
qui suivait ou dans les deux heures on a
eu un communiqué de presse très clair
qui nous après amy effectivement de nous
dérouler tout le protocole de
communication assez simplement puisque
tout était décrit dans le communiqué de
presse
la suite ça va être assez simple c'est
qu'on va essayer de donner au moins des
consignes aux joueurs pour essayer de
s'entretenir physiquement donc même
individuellement faire un peu de sport
et il apparemment ces mêmes
salvateur pour coronavirus donc on va
essayer de proposer ça et puis on va
voir ce qu'on va pouvoir faire pour pour
occuper un petit peu on a quelques idées
profiter de cette tendance pour faire
des systèmes de webinars par exemple
pour pouvoir former nos licenciés les
dirigeants etc webinar ça veut dire à
tes dont tout le monde dans son canapé
va pouvoir faire ça voilà on a plusieurs
idées on va voir ce qu'on va pouvoir
faire ma chantal fiscale au niveau
travail donc du coup c'est vrai que une
tension un peu stress au travail
du coup c'est vrai que le sport me
permet d'avoir une bouffée d'oxygène
donc c'est vrai que là c'est ben on va
faire avec les contraintes qu'on nous
impose malheureusement je pense qu'il
faut qu'on soit aussi raisonnables et
faire face à cette crise et vu le
contexte on pouvait s'attendre à une
abstention massive pour le premier tour
des élections municipales ils étaient au
programme hier et vous allez le voir
dans ce sujet de camille lambert les
électeurs ne se sont pas bousculés dans
les bureaux de vote comme à montigny le
bretonneux
ici comme partout en france les
recommandations d'hygiène ont été
appliquées marquage au sol pour
respecter une distance d'un mètre entre
les personnes port de masques et de
gants pour les assesseurs et surtout
mise à disposition de gel
hydroalcoolique des mesures nécessaires
pour lutter contre l'épidémie de
coronavirus mais pas encore ancré dans
les habitudes des électeurs et j'ai tout
respecter les mesures at elle voulait
que je les trouvais que j'ai mis ma
carte d'identité dans l'urne dans ce
bureau de vote de montigny le bretonneux
on ne se bouscule pas pour accéder aux
isoloirs
néanmoins le maire sortant jean luc
rigaut se montre optimiste à l'heure où
je vous parle
11' rosso modo on est à peu près au même
niveau
ou de vote que 2014 il va falloir voir
l'évolution dans la journée je dois
reconnaître que je ne m'attendais pas à
terminer un mandat va dire sur les
chapeaux de roue comme ça c'était
vraiment quelque chose qui n'était pas a
prévu son termine difficilement mais
sereinement quand même parce qu'on a
pris le maximum de précautions pour que
les gens puissent voter comme il faut
c'est notre devoir civique en vente au
saint malo exprès alors donc on est bien
notée mais puisque je comprends pas très
bien c'est que on permet aux gens de
venir voter voilà et entre partis y a
plus d'école il ya plus de magasins il
faut qu'on nous explique quand même la
chose l'armée bon une incompréhension
partagée par beaucoup d'habitants avec
la question de savoir si le deuxième
tour sera maintenu pour l'heure aucune
annulation n'est prévue et les
dépouillements de ce premier tour se
dérouleront normalement ou presque et
l'évolution a été mauvaise pour cette
journée de dimanche du premier tour des
élections municipales avec est des
chiffres de la participation
historiquement bas elle est estimée
cette participation pour le premier tour
dans les yvelines à 42 58% soit quasi 16
points et demi en moins par rapport au
scrutin de 2014
une abstention même supérieur par
rapport au niveau national où elle
s'élève à 53 5% selon les dernières
estimations une situation inédite qui
aurait pu être évitée selon stéphane
mans son doyen honoraire de la faculté
de droit et de sciences politiques de
l'ue vs qu reportait le premier tour
n'était pas impossible selon lui il
était notre invitée hier soir lors de
notre soirée spéciale élections
municipales sur tv 78 c'était absolument
pas obligatoire
ça s'est déjà vu
je ne sais plus quand d'ailleurs je joue
pourquoi c'est en 2014 ou le mandat des
conseils municipaux avait été prorogée
de deux mois pour que les deux scrutins
scrutin municipal et scrutin des
européennes coïncide donc le législateur
a tout loisir de prendre une loi
d'adopter une loi pour prolonger le
mandat des conseillers municipaux
le report de ce premier tour aurait été
tout à fait envisage un visage à bhl
jusque et y compris à un délai très
court de deux jours prévue
il suffisait pour cela il suffisait ça
se fait pas aussi simplement mais c'est
pas impossible juridiquement il
suffisait de prendre de demander au
premier ministre qu'il prenne un décret
retirant le décret initial par lequel il
avait convoqué leur électorat et il
fallait ensuite ça c'était plus délicat
réunir le parlement pour lui demander de
voter une loi prorogeant le mandat des
conseillers municipaux jusqu'en juin
jusqu'en septembre
voilà ça aurait été possible ça aurait
été compliqué la seconde partie du
dispositif faire voter la loi aurait été
compliqué dans les conditions qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui mais c'était pas
impossible mais la question qui se pose
désormais faut-il reporter le second
tour des élections municipales prévues
dimanche prochain pierre bédier
président du département des yvelines
nous donne son avis j'ai entendu ce soir
la plupart des partis à lire pour la
plupart des méfaits j'ai commencé à
écouter les premiers croire les chevaux
après soit clairement figé chipe la
diversion décide de reporter de 4000 fin
de semaine
le scrutin qui suspend dans les
compagnies avec droite parce que je
serai pas de confiner les gens et
d'avoir des campagnes électorales et il
faut bien entendu conférer des règles
hier on puisse pas recommencer
en tout cas le code électoral est formel
en cas de 2e tour de ce scrutin il doit
être procédé le dimanche suivant le
premier tour cela veut dire que
l'élection municipale est indissociable
elle forme un tout
ce cas un report dans le cas d'un report
du second tour le premier tour sera
considérée comme caduc et même en cas
d'élection de mer dès hier il faudra
revoter pour les deux tours dans ce cas
là le parlement réuni en session
extraordinaire devra voter dans la
semaine une loi pour prolonger le mandat
des conseillers municipaux sortants qui
expire le 31 mars prochain
ce scénario dont je vous parle est
valable sauf dispositions
exceptionnelles prévues par le
gouvernement et l'état aujourd'hui
edouard philippe le premier ministre a
demandé le report du second tour des
municipales au 21 juin et pour rappel
emmanuel macron doit s'exprimer sur le
sujet peut-être dans une allocution aux
français ce lundi soir à 20h côté
résultats à présent pour ce scrutin dans
les yvelines une dizaine de maire
sortant a été réélu dès le premier tour
de ce scrutin des municipales le point
avec mickaël landreau dans les yvelines
plusieurs maires ont été réélus dès ce
premier tour des municipales 2020 à
poissy karl olive liste divers droite
remporte l'élection dans cette ville de
37 mille habitants vainqueur en 2014
avec 62 42 % des voix ils l'emportent
encore plus largement ce dimanche 15
mars
ce candidat à totalise 75 60 % des
suffrages
la hauteur de ce résultat oui je dois
avouer que c'est parce que nous nous
attendions même si on était convaincus
du travail qui était fait vous savez
j'ai répété pendant six ans que la
réalité c est celle du terrain en
adéquation avec les habitants moi je
suis né ici j'ai grandi ici j'aime les
habitants comme
les habitants même je le crois à
saint-cyr-l'ecole la liste san siro
coeur 2020 mené par sonia broc maire de
la commune depuis février 2019 s'impose
avec 55 à 60% des suffrages face à la
liste menée par lydie du long pont
assange armand les arnaud péricard en
place depuis 2010 est a lui aussi
remporté son premier succès en tant que
tête de liste
l'homme politique diverse en totalise 63
89 % des suffrages il devance notamment
kane richard de la liste sans jardin
écologique et solidaire et ça prouve que
les saint germanois se retrouve dans le
projet que nous leur avons proposé dans
la rigueur qui est la nôtre dans le
sérieux et dans les projets que nous
avons pour notre ville pour les six
prochaines années
je crois que nous sommes des gens
crédibles nous l'avons démontré pendant
six ans il nous allons leur démontrer
sur les six prochaines années
à sartrouville pierrefonds maire
historique de la commune depuis 1995 va
repartir pour un nouveau mandat sa liste
sartrouville j'aime ma ville en porte
assez facilement avec 62 27 % des
suffrages le maire sortant devance
isabella maglio térisse a beau dire si
pas de souci pour les listes divers
droite philippe benassaya le maire
sortant en place depuis 2014 repartira
pour un nouveau mandat il devance e
jocelyne a nié avec 63 points 67 % à
vélizy-villacoublay pascal thévenot mer
depuis 2014 s'est lui aussi largement
imposée dès ce premier tour avec plus de
60% des suffrages
les trois autres candidats didier
blanchard hughes or seul un il ya six
mines à bellezane maths sont largement
distancés
c'est assez rare avait dit et puis il y
avait quand même quatre listes donc
c'était
par image obligatoirement faciles à
imaginer avant on a tout fait pour
puisque aujourd'hui
finalement on est un peu les seuls à
avoir un programme est maintenant c'est
un peu la satisfaction des visions sur
ce qu'on a fait ces six dernières années
à versailles commune de 85 mille
habitants françois de mazières le maire
divers-droite sortant partira pour un
troisième mandat comme en 2014 elle a
été élue dès le premier tour cette fois
c est que 63% des suffrages
quoique les versaillais ont été
satisfaits du bilan
en tout cas ils nous l'ont montré dans
le box et je rends remercie du fond du
coeur parce que la vie de mère c'est une
vie totalement engagé et c'est une vie
où finalement on a un sentiment
quasiment d'affection à mantes la jolie
le maire sortant rafael cogner en place
depuis décembre 2017 a été réélu avec 72
2% des suffrages et devance marc jamais
une liste divers gauche
enfin conflans sainte honorine a list
conflent en avant menée par laurent bros
remporte le premier tour avec plus de
51%
l'homme politique partira pour un
deuxième mandat consécutif à signaler
cette surprise la défaite de philippe
brillault aux chaînés rocancourt le
maire sortant perd son fauteuil pour 76
voix d'écart et les récoltes 49 points
56% des suffrages face à richard
delpierre qui l'emportent avec 50 44 %
des voix philippe brillault était maire
du chesnay depuis plus de 30 ans élu
pour la première fois en 1989 en deux en
2019 sa ville avait fusionné avec
rocancourt formant le chesnay rocancourt
une seule et même comme une nouvelle
focus à présent sur les résultats à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines certains
édiles sortants ont été reconduits dès
le premier tour par leurs administrés
c'est le cas dans cinq communes de
l'agglomération ont fait le point avec
aurélien sur les deux communes que
compte saint-quentin-en-yvelines cinq
maires ont été élus dès le premier tour
c'est didier fischer à coignières qui
fait le plus gros score de ce scrutin
il est élu avec 76 71 % des voix face à
exalter girard on a une participation
qui est relativement faible
je pense qu'elle est au dessus quand
même de la participation nationale ce
qui prouve que quand même sur coignières
on sait
mobilisés avec un écart de plus de 3
points d'un bureau à l'autre
gros score aussi pour bertrand ou lyon
le maire divers gauche de magny les
hameaux remporte un peu plus de 68 % des
suffrages pour son troisième mandat
on a fait le travail avec nos équipes
d'abord avec l'équipe municipale avec un
partage des bilans avec ensuite un
collectif qui s'est organisée au fur et
à mesure des mois en fin d'année 2010
9,1 collectif ouvert en dehors des
partis avec un certain nombre de valeurs
qui ont fondé notre travail en commun à
montigny le bretonneux pour sa première
candidature lors à un merckaert était
face à deux listes à l'issue de ce
premier tour il emporte avec 62 70 % des
voix je suis très heureux ce soir
évidemment que la liste que j'ai
présentées montrent signé ensemble est
le programme que nous allons proposer
aux habitants rencontre un tel succès
auprès de auprès de la population et
nîmes antenne c'est une vraie
satisfaction évidemment pour nous ce
soir
comment 2014 jean michel fourgous est
élu dès le premier tour à elancourt avec
malgré tout un score un peu moins
important 56 93 % contre 60 % il ya six
ans pour ce scrutin 2020 de liste était
face à lui bien entendu on est toujours
très heureux d'avoir la confiance de ses
administrés surtout quand on les connaît
comme d'année on est fiers avec mon
équipe bien sûr d'avoir cette confiance
renouvelée
enfin cinquième maire à saint quentin en
yvelines avoir été élu dès le premier
tour grégory gare et astier le maire
sortant de maurepas l'emporta avec 51,13
% dévouera un score historique puisque
jusqu'à présent aucun maire dans cette
commune avait été élu dès le premier
tour
évidemment une grande fierté c'est la
récompense du travail accompli depuis
six ans maintenant avec mon équipe
le travail de terrain paye énormément la
confiance des électeurs en leur mère
évidemment la récompense aussi du fait
que on a mené une campagne positive et
constructive
cette commune saint-quentinoise au
contraire auront besoin d'un deuxième
tour pour élire leur maire si certains
ballottage sont favorables
la situation est plus complexe pour
d'autres comme à villepreux et rap
nicolas kirillovitch
il n'est pas encore élu mais pour ces
soutiens le doute n'est plus permis à
lire ab arrive en tête du premier tour
pour les élections municipales à trappes
avec près de 37% des voix il devance de
10 points ses principaux concurrents
je salue aussi mes concurrents qui sont
arrivés deuxièmes et troisièmes autres
menaces coups qui incarne la droite
trappistes qui a rassemblé 6 frage de la
famille politique qui est la sienne à
27% et guy malandain maire sortant qui
arrivait en troisième position que je
salue pour le travail qu'il a pu
réaliser pendant maintenant plus de 20
ans mais que j'invite à prendre ses
responsabilités dans un cadre classique
et celui de du rassemblement deuxième
tour de la gauche républicaine est
distancé après 20 ans de mandat le maire
sortant guy malandain ne semble pas
disposer pour l'instant à soutenir son
ancien adjoint à la jeunesse et aux
sports
si vraiment un deuxième tour confirmé le
premier tour j'ai beaucoup d'inquiétude
pour l'avenir de la ville
il ya des gens de droite des maires de
droite que je connais qui gèrent bien
leur vie des maires de gauche y gère pas
bien dans huile et vice versa trois
situations compliquées aussi à
villepreux pour le maire sortant
stéphane mirambeau n'est que troisième
du premier tour avec un peu moins de 19%
des suffrages exprimés il est largement
devancé par son ancien adjoint jean
baptiste à monique premier en récoltant
39% des voix des villes pro ziem depuis
les dernières semaines de campagne on
sentait une vraie dynamique sur le
terrain une dynamique qui s'amplifiait
de jour en jour nous on va continuer
droits dans nos bottes en tout cas on va
continuer à dérouler le projet qu'on a
présenté au premier tour
on maintient le cap on en tire la ligne
et puis on sera dans une logique
évidemment de rassemblement quand on
faisait un mail numéro 3 alors qu'on est
le maire depuis 12 depuis douze ans
qu'on a un bilan qui est quand même
plutôt pas mal
on est quand même extrêmement déçu de
terminer 3 à ce stade je peux vous
assurer que je serai encore présents
avec les membres de ma liste est gérée
elle déposé tout cela à la préfecture
demain je ne baisse pas les bras
en tout cas je ne je me battrai jusqu'au
bout bien évidemment pas de maire
sortant aux clayes-sous-bois mais
plusieurs anciens élus de la majorité en
ballottage pour le second tour anne
claire frémont se place troisième avec
24% des voix nicolas hulot candidat de
la gauche et membre de l'opposition
municipale récolte lui 26% c'est
philippe guiguen l'actuel adjoint aux
finances qui se place en tête avec 31 7
% de votants pour sa liste enfin eux
aussi font la course en tête après ce
premier tour les maires des villes de
plaisir guyancourt voisins le bretonneux
et la verrière peuvent aborder le second
tour plus ou moins sereinement si second
tour il y est sûre ces derniers
ballottage le président sortant de saint
quentin en yvelines jean michel fourgous
n'est pas inquiet il ne décideront pas
selon lui d'une potentielle alternance
au sein de la collectivité de majorité
de droite depuis le dernier scrutin de
2014 écoutez le au micro de nicolas
d'andrus je pense pas qu aura de gros
soucis sur sur sur la présidence si
c'est la question que vous me posez sur
la présidence de de saint quentin où des
gens sont venus ont fait signe c'est
clairement de de leur choix et que on
conserve bien sûr la même gouvernance
donc je suis très flatté de ce petit
move mais attendons bien entendu le
fameux secundo parce que j'avais vu ça
je mets une situation pareille mais en
tout cas on à saint quentin ça se passe
bien
bon bien sûr et tout le mystère de
trappes laperrière aussi qu'il faut
suivre mais ça change pas la majorité
choses soient claires à des ballottages
également dans d'autres villes des
yvelines à mantes-la-ville seules
communes franciliennes du rassemblement
national le maire sortant cyril note
arrive en tête avec 33 72% des voix le
candidat sami damerdji soutenu par la
république en marche se classe 2e
viennent ensuite la liste union de
gauche d'amity smith d'aguilat lice
divers gauche de romain carbone et qui
recueille 1 14 82% des suffrages
déception également pour le candidat
divers droite éric visant nerfs qui
termine cinquième avec un peu plus de 6%
réaction de cyril noté d'amis this
mestdagh y au micro est d' arnaud lebrun
pour l fn c'est évidemment satisfaisant
d'être en pole position mais mais je
note que l'effet coronavirus a sans
doute eu un impact négatif à moi je
tablais sur beaucoup plus j'ai pu
constater qu'effectivement beaucoup de
personnes âgées de seniors ne sont pas
venus voter aujourd'hui en raison du
contexte sanitaire je regrette cette
situation je pense que ça fausse en
partie le résultat de cette élection
pour le moment nous savons clairement
que nous ne voulons plus du front
national à mantes la ville et donc nous
allons nous réunir et discuter avec nos
partenaires pour décider de la meilleure
décision à prendre pour atteindre cet
objectif
on fera ce qu'il faut pour que le front
national ne soit paré aux mureaux les
électeurs avaient le choix entre cinq
listes pour le premier tour avec un taux
de participation très faible c'est la
liste du maire sortant françois garay
qui arrive en tête avec 46 77 % des voix
à la liste divers droite 10 d'hervé riou
arrive en deuxième position la liste
divers gauche et d'agnès étendard se
maintient pour le second tour avec 21
points 47% des voix la liste
rassemblement national de nicolas
brisson est quatrième
alain riguet tête de liste de lutte
ouvrière faire entendre le camp des
travailleurs recueille seulement 2% des
voix
et puis à rambouillet pas de maire
sortant marc robert ne se représentait
pas pour raison de santé mais à l'issue
de ce premier tour la candidate de la
majorité sortante se démarque et
véronique matillon arrive en tête avec
43 82 % des voix le candidat écologiste
est david jussiê lui créé la surprise en
obtenant l 27 25 % des suffrages
déception en revanche pour gilles
schmitt le candidat investi par lrm qui
termine à la troisième place est la
liste de gauche de jean marc keller est
loin derrière avec un peu plus de 6%
l'élection à rambouillet qui a été
marquée par un faible taux de
participation avec 41,26 % pour ce taux
qui est similaire
parmi toutes les communes des yvelines
des propos sont recueillis par françois
poulet une grande joie
effectivement après
une belle campagne menée par une équipe
qui est très soudée que je remercie
sincèrement oui on nous avons fait une
belle campagne
le résultat est là ce soir malgré bien
entendu une participation nettement
inférieure à la partie à la
participation habituelle
nous on a créé un collectif pour porter
des valeurs est en tout cas quel que
soit ce qui va arriver ensuite on va
continuer de porter ces valeurs et dans
les quartiers comme on l'a fait auprès
des gens si les élections présidentielle
et législatives de 2010 est ont bousculé
le paysage politique national au niveau
local elle les partis et mouvements
politiques traditionnels ont démontré
leur subsistance le rassemblement de la
droite et du centre sort vainqueur de ce
scrutin municipal dans les yvelines
statu quo pour la gauche à cause de sa
division quant au parti de la république
en marche
il n'a pas réussi son pari dans le
département les détails avec ce sujet de
nicolas landry
c'est une victoire pour le rassemblement
de la droite et du centre au niveau des
yvelines de nombreux candidats issus de
la majorité au conseil départemental
sympathisants du parti les républicains
ou classé divers droite sont élus au
premier tour arrive en tête des
élections municipales
c'est le cas notamment de karl olive à
poissy de jean michel fourgous à
elancourt ou d'arnaud perica à saint
germain en laye ce succès se fait aux
dépens de la république en marche
le mouvement du président de la
république rade son pari dans les
yvelines principales illustrations la
quatrième position dan france simon
candidate investie à versailles
loin derrière le maire sortant françois
de mazières réélu avec 63% des suffrages
autre exemple à rambouillet gilles
schmitt arrive en troisième position
avec 22% des voix devant lui véronique
matillon candidates issues de la
majorité sortante et l'écologiste david
jutier puis à limay sébastien dupré
investi par la république en marche
arrive en dernière position avec 11%
loin derrière le candidat communiste
eric rouleau autre succès d'une
candidature communiste signe du maintien
de la gauche dans ses bastions à la
verrière la maire sortante nelly duthu
arrive en tête avec 40% des suffrages
pas de succès au 1er tour à cause de la
division des candidatures de gauche
même situation à trappes ou à guyancourt
françois morton arrive
en tête mais une candidature commune
avec olivier paréja aurait pu obtenir
plus de 58% des voix
à noter la réussite des candidature
écologiste à rambouillet andrésy et
carrières sous poissy
enfin le rassemblement national confirme
son implantation à mantes-la-ville seule
commune dirigée par une majorité issus
du parti de marine le pen le candidat
cyril note obtient 33 % des suffrages
cette édition spéciale touche à sa fin
je vous le rappelle dans les yvelines au
dernier point avec qui nous a été
communiquée à 18h par la préfecture du
département
il y à sept décès qui sont recensés sur
le territoire 174 cas confirmés ce lundi
soir le président de la république
emmanuel macron doit s'exprimer devant
les français
à 20h sur le sujet dans ce contexte si
particulier la rédaction de tv 60,18
fera tout son possible pour garantir une
continuité de l'information avec
forcément des effectifs et moyens
réduits l'actualité de notre chaîne en
tout cas est aussi à retrouver sur nos
réseaux sociaux et applications mobiles
voilà suivait bien toutes les
recommandations qui sont donnés par le
gouvernement et bonne soirée tout de
même sur tv 78
[Musique]
et